biggest liberal media embarrassments
ever michael avenatti is headed to the
slammer for two and a half years
for trying to extort nike there was a
time when you couldn't avoid seeing the
slime ball on those liberal networks
and they heaped endless praise on
avenatti who turned out to be a total
fraud
he's out there saving the country you
know what he's a rock star i think
michael avenatti is a beast you're like
the holy spirit you are
all places at all times sitting beside
me right now i'm not going to let you
cheat you have to guess
uh hint his name is michael avenatti
okay
here's something else michael avenatti
i'd like to meet you sometime over
at dinner you got lucky tonight we're
back with attorney michael avenatti he
is a main player looking ahead to 2020
one reason why i'm taking you seriously
as a contender is because of your
presence on cable news
the holy spirit greg yeah and how ironic
is she's ghosting him now
you know it's like he was he was seduced
by all
of his new famous friends and by the way
they're all hacks
they're all worms to a degen i think
said yesterday is that the reason why it
worked they they all fell in together
because they're the same thing
they're both they're all he's a social
climber all those people with maybe the
exception of rachel maddow
are social climbers they want to impress
their peers
in the industry they wanted to be near
him because you know he
he was getting a lot of the spotlight
and so they wanted to hang around with
him i think in 2024 when he's
out he could immediately enter the cnn
lineup i'm pretty sure by then don lemon
will be gone
i think brian stelter or anna navarro
should show up in jail with a pie
perhaps with a file in it since maybe
they could spring this poor guy
you know but he's you know he's he's
he's
i love this too much i can't i want to
say anything else because i'm talking
about it on my show tonight
i'll shut up i was put off by the fact
that hosts were sucking up to a guest
should never happen yes never happened
that way it's supposed to be the other
way dana
unless we're guests on greg's show and
then then of course that's not going to
be allowed
i i'm for uh the criminal justice system
they found him guilty
he's been convicted he's been sentenced
and now he's going to go to jail he also
faces two other
big problems i mean and uh so look uh
the system works
the media did not and this is just uh
one in many times where the media
latched their wagons onto a fraud
remember smollette
they bought into him and they just blew
right up in their face
hillary clinton crooked as greg said
that's her i did say that
why do you guys keep getting duped
jessica
i was gonna say i was impressed that it
turned into the top
liberal media screw up there because i
feel like there are there's so many to
choose from
well i knew that there would be many
mentioned at this table not necessarily
but that's what i think about um i
never liked michael avenatti and i'm not
just saying that you could like check
all the tapes
and whoever thinks that they can extort
nike
yes is really dumb yeah you got to go
after new balance unless you're a
diversity consultant
oh yeah right unless you're a diversity
you can extort anybody
they'll call you a racist if you don't
give them megan
what exemplifies this man's stupidity is
the fact
based on the other two trials he had
already allegedly
stolen money from his clients years
before he started doing his
gollum on cnn and msnbc including from a
mentally ill paraplegic man allegedly
but
i heard someone earlier in the day say
on tv a giant come down for the once
famous lawyer
and i thought is prison really worse
than being on brian's delta
that also i saw falls from not as good
food i saw a headline i think it was
somewhere else i hope it's somewhere
else that said fall from grace
like really there was no grace but you
know people
if you think that we're overdoing it on
this you can't let the media
forget about avenatti we can't let him
disappear we've got to hang him
around their neck because they whenever
they they do something wrong
they run screaming from it and they
never get their comeuppance
we have to remind them and remember what
he did to brett kavanaugh yeah that's
the other thing is that he didn't go to
he's not being convicted for that yeah
but that was outrageous
what swetnick is up to if she's happy or
sad by this
good point comeuppance people that's
what you get
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else